hello everybody producer pat ford here
filling in for david pakman on another
exciting edition of the david pakman
show fear not david is going to be back
on monday but for today at least on this
christmas eve edition of the show you
are all stuck with me but that's okay
because we're going to talk about a lot
of interesting stuff we're going to talk
about uh build back better we're going
to talk about joel manchin we're going
to talk about omicron and the latest
coveted surge so let's get right into
the news as we know this week joe
manchin effectively killed the build
back better legislation in its current
forum the 1.9 trillion dollar social
spending plan is not going to get passed
this year and it's not going to get
passed in its current forum uh mansion
went on fox news sunday with brett bear
and he told him look i'm just not going
to support this thing so as of now it's
dead in the water chief among mansion's
reasons for opposing the bill were that
he believed it would add to the national
debt he believed it would further
accelerate the rate of inflation in the
united states and he just gave this
general sentiment of look we're we're
spending so much money as it is right
now we can't possibly afford to spend
any more so some of this economic
fear-mongering stuff that we will often
hear from the centrists and the right
wing of this country of course depending
on the circumstances well goldman sachs
ran the numbers and they found that
actually not passing buildback better is
going to cost the us economy money
because the spending plan would infuse
60 billion dollars into the gross
domestic product a team of economists at
goldman predicted that the us gdp would
grow three percent in the first quarter
of 2022 if buildback better were passed
3.5
in the second quarter and another three
percent in the third quarter of 2022
that's again if buildback better was
signed into law this year now the
estimate uh without the spending plan in
place because they redid the numbers uh
is that two percent uh is going to be
the rate of growth for the first quarter
three percent is going to be the rate of
growth for the second quarter and 2.75
percent in the third quarter of 2022 and
when you line up all of those numbers
you compare the percentages you run the
raw numbers the differences add up to 60
billion dollars in economic losses for
the first three quarters of 2022 and of
course it's probably going to add up to
a lot more than that because it's only
counting for the first three quarters of
the year and obviously the impacts of
buildback better are going to extend far
beyond 2022. now of course we have to
include some caveats here like for
example just because we're not going to
get the 1.9 trillion dollar legislation
there's a good chance that we get
something done right i mean maybe it'll
be 500 billion maybe it'd be a trillion
maybe it'll be 1.5 trillion dollars we
just don't yet know what the total is
going to be and we don't know what
provisions are going to get passed yet
and unfortunately it seems to be really
up to mansion and what he wants to do
but we'll probably see some boost to the
gdp numbers compared to those more
conservative estimates second of all you
can never fully predict what the us
economy is going to do sometimes we hear
estimates from financial institutions or
government agencies about what we expect
job numbers to be or what we expect the
stock market to be at months down the
line years down the line and it's always
just a guess i mean you can make an
educated guess certainly but you never
know until it actually happens you can't
fully predict the us economy and what
it's going to do but these estimates
certainly do seem to jive with the
reality of the economy and what we know
about demand side stimulus because if
you think about it if you go to these
different provisions on the bill
one of the key provisions is extending
the child tax credit of three thousand
dollars or three thousand six hundred
dollars depending on the age of the
child uh per year um per child it works
out so that if people have this extra
money in their pocket they're going to
be able to spend it on things like going
out to dinner or going on vacation or
birthday presents or whatever the case
may be and the same can be said about
the other provisions too right because
people can save some money on the cost
of elder care or child care or
healthcare costs or prescription drug
costs and so with that extra money
people can go out and participate in the
economy and it can be economically
stimulative so i understand why this
conservative argument will sometimes win
the day because it just seems so
intuitive right like if we just don't
spend the money that means that we're
going to save the money but it's
actually quite the opposite and that's
exactly what these goldman sachs numbers
show us
and we of course know that republicans
are going to make this argument we know
that they love to fearmonger about
inflation and spending and the debt and
the deficit of course they only do that
when a democrat is in charge they don't
care so much about these things when a
republican is in the white house we saw
that last year with donald trump
compared to joe biden this year i mean
these these things like inflation and
spending they were all going on under
the trump administration last year only
now do they care about these things but
what's upsetting is that someone who is
supposed to be a democrat joe manchin he
also buys into these talking points and
ultimately that's going to harm the
people of west virginia and it's going
to harm the country as a whole because
it's going to cost the u.s economy
billions of dollars going into next year